[Music]  hey quick announcement tomorrow night's  show is very special for two reasons  first we're going to shoot our show on a  really tiny replica of this set with  guest shaquille o'neal  that just  that's going to  be yeah we've tried to do this many  times yeah tomorrow we're doing it and i  think that should be interesting uh to  make it more special i'll be providing  live commentary on our new super cool  team coco app  while the show airs there she is  now they love apps they love apps  you can see what i think about the show  as it all goes horribly wrong because  this thing syncs up with your tv that  tells you exactly what we're thinking  about it while it's going on to be very  cool you'll need the team coco tablet  app available at teamcoco.com  to go and guess what it is free  absolutely free  you pay nothing  how am i going gonna make money off this  thing i i don't know you should have  thought of that before i said we'll make  it free i'll make millions uh